what your favorite whatever says about  you you're going with the safe Choice  maybe a bit basic but you're not wrong  is this one really your favorite or were  you just told it should be you're either  really awesome or you really suck no  middle ground  you are the middle ground you are a very  neutral person  you like the classics hey that's my  dad's favorite hey that's my mom's  favorite  you pretentious [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]  hipster  you're cool like actually cool you are  what the hipsters think they are you are  a child  and I mean that literally like you're  not yet a teenager you are a child and I  mean that as an insult  you are a contrarian  you do not exist this is no one's  favorite  this one shouldn't even count  but I'll let it slide